Y
SAT DOWN WITH HIM AGAIN FOR A
BRAND-NEW EPISODE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WHAT I SAW WAS SOMETHING THAT
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE WHICH IS I
LIKE THE CIVILIZATION I CAME
FROM.
I LOVED IT, I WANTED TO
CONTINUE.
I THOUGHT IT HAD ALL SORTS OF
WONDERFUL, NURTURING THE THINGS
THAT I WANTED OTHER PEOPLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO AS WELL.
I DIDN'T WANT TO TEAR DOWN MY
SOCIETY, I WANTED TO KEEP IT UP
AND THAT IS THE CONSERVATIVE
INSTINCT.
THEN I REALIZED I HAD IT EVEN
HAS A LOT OF MY CONTEMPORARIES
MANY OF WHOM WERE FIRM FAR MORE
PRIVILEGED BACKGROUNDS THAT
MYSELF THOUGHT THEY SHOULD TEAR
DOWN THEIR SOCIETY AND RADICALLY
ALTER IT AND I JUST DIDN'T SHARE
THAT VIEW HIM GRADUALLY CAME TO
THE REALIZATION THAT THIS WAS AN
UNUSUAL POSITION I HELD, BUT IT
WAS CORRECT.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU WERE
ACTING OUT OF INSTINCT.
>> YOU GET IT AT CERTAIN POINTS
OF YOUR LIFE WHERE SOME GREAT
INFLUENCE FRIEND OF MINE
DESCRIBED TO ME THAT HIS
REALIZATION CAME IN PARIS IN
1968 WHEN HE SAW THESE
MIDDLE-CLASS STUDENTS THROWING
BRICKS THAT WORKING-CLASS
POLICEMAN AND REALIZED THAT HE
WANTED PARIS, LIKE LONDON TO
CONTINUE.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO TEAR IT DOWN
AND I HAD A SIMILAR, MORE
DRAMATIC REALIZATION OF A
SIMILAR INSTINCT IN MY
ADOLESCENCE I SUPPOSE.
I DIDN'T WANT TO DESTROY THE
SOCIETY.
I THOUGHT IT COULD BE IMPROVED,
BUT I HAD TO CONTINUE.
I DIDN'T THINK THAT THE OTHER
THINGS ON OFFER WERE BETTER.
I DIDN'T THINK THE DREAMS OF THE
RADICAL LEFT SOUNDED GOOD TO ME.
I DIDN'T LIKE -- THESE ARE
INSTINCT THINGS AS YOU KNOW, BUT
I DIDN'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
EVERYONE BEING THE SAME.
I JUST THOUGHT IT WAS A BORING
VIEW OF SOCIETY.
I DIDN'T WANT US ALL TO LIVE IN
THE SAME HOUSES ARE SAME THE
GARDENS.
>> BEFORE I KNEW IT, I DIDN'T
WANT EVERYONE TO HAVE THE SAME
VIEWS AND HAVE TO BE THE SAME
BOOKS AND LIKE THE SAME THINGS.
I THOUGHT THAT DIFFERENT WAS A
WONDERFUL THING AND THAT DIDN'T
MEAN THAT UNFAIRNESS WOULDN'T
EXIST OR SHOULD BE CELEBRATED,
BUT YES, I DIDN'T LIKE THE OFFER
THAT THE LEFT WAS HOLDING OUT TO
ME AS A VERY INSTINCTIVE LEVEL,
SO I ACCIDENTALLY BECAME A
CONSERVATIVE.
>> I THINK YOU HAVE UNUSUAL
CLARITY.
YOU CAN SEE THINGS VERY CLEARLY
AS THEY HAPPEN AND THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY THE FIRST STEP TO
IMPROVING THINGS AND YOU ALSO
HAVE A BALANCED LIFE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS MAELSTROM.
>> WE HAVE TO BALANCE OUR LIVES,
DON'T WE?
WE ALL KNOW PEOPLE WHO'VE GONE
MAD IN RECENT YEARS.
SOME PEOPLE QUITE CLOSE TO US
AND IT'S BECAUSE WE HAVE LOST
PERSPECTIVE.
WE HAVE LOST PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT
MATTERS, LOST PERSPECTIVE ON HOW
TO VIEW THINGS IN THE CORRECT
PERSPECTIVE TO LOOK AT LIFE AND
WE HAVE LOST A LOT AND WE HAVE
TO REGAIN IT.
I DON'T THINK THINGS LOST ARE
IMPOSSIBLE TO REGAIN.
WE LIVE IN THIS ERA WHERE WE
IMAGINE THAT WE CAN KNOW
ANYTHING BECAUSE WE CAN GOOGLE
IT.
BUT WE LOST WISDOM, WE HAVE LOST
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE,
PERSPECTIVE AND WE HAVE TO FIND
A WAY TO GET BACK TO THAT.
I THINK ONE WAY BACK TO IT IS TO
ADMIRE IT AND TO SEEK TO GET IT
BACK.
TO ADMIRE PEOPLE WHO MANY THINK
WE DON'T KNOW, THAT SEEMS TO BE
COMPLETELY LOST IN OUR ERA,
EVERYBODY THINKS THEY KNOW
EVERYTHING.
AND CAN LECTURE EVERYONE ELSE
BECAUSE OF THAT.
>> ARE YOU SURPRISED BY THE
IGNORANCE ON THIS?
>> AMERICAN IGNORANCE IS A
RELIC.
IT >> AMERICAN IGNORANCE IS HER
>> I HAVE SPENT ALL MY LIFE IS
AN ADMIRER OF AMERICA, GREAT
FRIENDS AND FROM THE MOMENT I
FIRST CAME TO THIS COUNTRY, I
LOVED AND ADMIRED IT BUT MY GOD,
IT'S GONE WRONG.
NOW WHEN THE STAGE WHERE MY OWN
COUNTRY OF BIRTH GREAT BRITAIN
ARE ACTUALLY HAPPY TO TRY TO CUT
OURSELVES OFF FROM AMERICAN
INFLUENCE AND THAT'S HOW BAD
AMERICA HAS BECOME.
THE FRENCH AS YOU KNOW, THE
FRENCH HAVE TRIED TO CUT
THEMSELVES OFF FROM THAT.
THE PRESIDENT OF FRANCE I DID
RECENTLY SAY WE CAN'T HAVE THESE
AMERICAN IMPORTS OF IDEAS.
THE FRENCH ACADEMY, FRENCH
ACADEMICS ARE SAYING WE CAN'T
ALLOW THIS AMERICAN IMPORTS IN.
WHAT IS THE IMPORT?
IT IS STUPIDITY.
IT IS EVANGELICAL